what a sweet run it's been
forces of darkness and bye
we have the job that anyone else would
love to have so when we go to work we
have a really good time I'd like to
explore the Falcon as a character what
kind of man is this man
we'll find out we don't want it to be
all action all the time I'll do my best
we need to go home with these characters
we need to spend time or really
unearthing who they are and since we've
got great actors put them in situations
where they really get to show what they
can do we can create the same exciting
high end action sequences but then in
between those set pieces we get to dive
deeper into the character piece so it's
the best of both worlds
I'll be seeing you very soon Daniel
Bruhl is returning as Baron Zemo from
Civil War
Sharon Carter's returning miss Emily
they can't it's going to be an epic
adventure I think I'm so excited to be
here and a new character entering the
MCU in this series is a character named
John Walker and he's played by the great
Wyatt Russell gentlemen welcome back
everyone
is Charlie this is going to be my breakdown
of the Marvel phase 4 trailer for Falcon
and winter soldiers that they just
dropped there's a whole bunch of Marvel
phase 4 stuff happening this week so I
will do footage for all the different
trailers that they dropped over the next
couple of days be sure to subscribe to
get everything we're also still doing
that Avengers infinity saga giveaway -
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Marvel phase 4 series that's coming up
on the video so they served with Iron
Man's voice over opening the trailer
lots of voiceover from the original
Avengers introducing the Marvel phase 4
trailers the old guard classic
characters teeing up the new stuff
pretty standard tactic then you get the
transition to the full official Falcon
and Winter Soldier logo notice how they
rotate it and it starts with winter
soldiers classic Russian armed with the
red star but it extends into a shiny
metal version of Falcons wings because
it's both Falcon and Winter Soldier
together teaming up the reason they
team-up will become clear in a second
when they introduce all the antagonists
Baron Zemo is technically the main
villain but there are a lot of other
people Falcon and Winter Soldier will be
fighting against from the US government
side of things Thunderbolt
Ross's people now the cap has officially
retired and passed the mantle and the
shield on Thunderbolt Ross feels like
the shield belongs to the US government
so that's going to become a big problem for Falcon and Winter Soldier during the
series they rotate the logo and it's
made to look like a version of the
American flag but they transpose Captain
America's shield where the stars would
be because cap has passed the shield in
the mantle to Falcon at the end of
Avengers endgame only thing bumming me out is the fact that to live in a world
without Captain America
it reminds me
they actually explained after the movie
came out that Bucky here in this moment
before cap goes back in time to return
the stones and Thor's hammer to where
they took them from he knew exactly what cap was going to do and that's why he
gives them that strange look of knowing
and says I'm going to miss you buddy like
he knows that he's not coming right back
he's going to go and live his life with
Peggy Carter and maybe he'll see him
again but it'd be a vastly changed
version of him and before this moment
here the writers said that he and Bucky
had already had a really long talk about
what was going to happen and their life
together like they're sort of really
long goodbyes
that's why cap only has the conversation
with Falcon at the end of the movie
instead of having a long conversation
with Bucky plus if you're mad they
didn't get a moment together at the end
of the movie you have to imagine that
after this moment here it's implied that
they helped Captain America settle down
in their reality somewhere quiet
in case they ever needed his help again
but for all intents and purposes he's
retired and decide from flashbacks Kevin
Feige and Chris Evans haven't really
said anything about old cap coming back
for cameos during the Falcon and Winter
Soldier episodes but maybe there will be
a small old cap surprise then they talk
about the premise of the series what
happens to these two characters between
the Avengers movies when the Avengers
are off doing other things on their own
- they kind of gave you a preview of
that during Avengers infinity war there
was a prelude comic book that featured
Captain America's Secret Avengers they
spent most of their time between Captain
America Civil War and Avengers infinity
war dismantling the International aliens
armed trade remember spider-man
homecoming the vulture and the Tinker
were selling shatori weapons all over
the New York tri-state area
caps Secret Avengers were taking care of
that on a much much bigger scale they
reintroduced Baron Zemo as the main
villain wearing his comic-book purple
mask finally his rumored plot during the
series will be trying to release some
crazy nerve gas biological agent around
the world and Falcon and Winter Soldier
had to stop him then capture him enroute
to getting him ready for a thunderbolt
series down the road with Thunderbolt
Ross there were a bunch of reports last
week that Thunderbolts had gone into
development officially but no date on
when they would release that series then
we get
look at their brand-new uniforms bucky
looking like he's cleaned up big-time
and wearing a captain america variant of
his Avengers infinity war costume even
more like the Captain America costume
that he's ever been before they added
the star back to his vibranium arm but
it's a white star for America instead of
the red Russian star the Falcon suit is
also interesting because it's not as
much like the Captain America's suit as
I expected so in the comics Falcon
eventually takes the mantle of Captain
America but this is what the suit that
he wears looks like when he does that
the reddish looking suit that he's
wearing in this series looks a lot more
like the suit that Falcon wears after he
gives back the mantle in the shield -
Captain America in the comics at least
in the comics he stopped being Captain
America a couple years ago and just went
back to being Falcon but Anthony Mackie
actually did say during an interview
that he would not be replacing Captain
America during this series this is the
clip of him talking about that Captain
America so is this is the title changing
how does that work
no I'm the Falcon I will always be the
Falcon the moniker will stay the same so
hearing him say that and then seeing
that he's not wearing a Captain America
looking costume I think there's a reason
for that and it also involves what's
going on with Thunderbolt Ross during
the series so I'll explain that in a
second but he is wearing the special
straps that Captain America wore to
holster his shield on his back so he
will be using the shield during the
series Sharon Carter is coming back as
the main character she has a much more
hardcore suit just meaning she's going to
see way more action this time she's
still working for the world Security
Council and Thunderbolt Ross
I'll explain her role in a second
because she's kind of stuck in the
middle between a couple different
factions the other new character is
actually pretty interesting John Walker
is his name he's also known as u.s.
agent in the comics he's kind of one of
the other antagonists he's the new
version of Captain America that's on the
government and Thunderbolt Ross's
payroll the version of Captain
America that Thunderbolt Ross wants to
be Captain America we're starting to get
into Dark Avengers territory here so
I'll explain what's going on with that
too because that sort of gets into the
Thunderbolt series John Walker in the
comics wore the mantle of Captain
America for a brief period he was a
super hardcore Punisher esque version of
Captain America
before Steve Rogers took the mantle back
what they're basically saying is is a
Thunderbolt Ross in this series is not
cool at all with Falcon having the
shield so you'll probably see a battle
for the shield situation going on during
the series if you're a big Batman fan
remember battle for the cowl with a
bunch of Batman's people fighting for
the right to become the next Batman same
idea only with the mantle of Captain
America who has the right to be the next
Captain America is it the person that
Captain America wants to become the next
Captain America or is it Thunderbolt
Ross who technically owns the rights to
the shield remember Ironman at the end
of Captain America Civil War my father
made that shield it doesn't belong to
you
so all those questions will be answered
during the Falcon and Winter Soldier
series Sharon Carter is kind of caught
in the middle between those different
factions between the Thunderbolt Ross
people and between Falcon and Winter
Soldier in Baron Zemo because she's on
thunderbolt Ross's payroll but she's
also team cap so Falcon and Winter
Soldier are her friends and she's trying
to help them take down Baron Zemo while also trying to keep Thunderbolt Ross
from messing everything up so if we're
talking about future Dark Avengers plans
or Thunderbolts series evil or dark
versions of the Avengers characters John
Walker would be their version of dark
Captain America on that team and if they
have problems using Norman Osborn to
lead a Dark Avengers team or a
Thunderbolts team early speculation
they'll probably wind up using a version
of Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross or just
Thunderbolt Ross there's supposed to be
some kind of teaser for that during the
Black Widow movie so just be prepared
for Thunderbolts set up post-credit
scenes but post all your theories in the
comments below I've got a new black Adam video that I'm working on but a
hopefully post later today while you
wait for everything click here for my
brand new Avengers what if trailer
breakdown and click here for my brand
new Star Wars the Mandalorian episode 1
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight!